Amazon's journey to the Dark Tower is over.
Amazon Studios has opted to pass on its planned
adaptation of Stephen King's eight-novel opus
after reportedly being dissatisfied with the
pilot.
This comes a little more than two years after
the feature film, starring Idris Elba and
Matthew McConaughey.
The streamer will shop its two completed scripts
to other studios, according to Deadline.
The news comes as a bit of a shock.
King fans were psyched for The Dark Tower
to receive the serial treatment, which would
have been a great fit for the extremely dense
and profoundly weird material.
The novel series deals with Roland, the last
of a long line of near-mythical Gunslingers,
and his quest to ascend the titular Tower,
which is the nexus of all possible realities.
He's opposed by the mysterious Man in Black,
as well as the Crimson King, an evil extradimensional
entity who has featured directly or indirectly
in several of King's works.
While Amazon had made no official announcements
regarding the series' cast and crew, it had
been widely reported that the series showrunner
was Glen Mazzara, who had worked on The Walking
Dead and The Shield; Sam Strike and Jasper
Pääkkönen had been cast as Roland and the
Man in Black, respectively, and Guardians
of the Galaxy's Michael Rooker and Jerome
Flynn from Game of Thrones had also joined
the series in undisclosed roles.
Unfortunately, unless the series is picked
up by another network or streamer, Mazzara's
Dark Tower will never see the light of day.
Fans who were disappointed by the 2017 feature
film, which attempted to cram several novels'
worth of story into one film and...well, failed,
now have something else to be disappointed
about.
"Jackpot!"
Amazon has made no public statement about
why the plug was pulled on the series, but
Deadline's sources indicate that it wasn't
just one thing.
Of course, as one might have predicted, it
was reported that Mazzara and company were
having a tough time wrangling the material.
What works on the page doesn't always work
on the screen, and the Dark Tower novels serve
as an absolutely splendid illustration of
this truth.
Some of their imagery would be near-impossible
to depict, and some of it, if we're being
honest, would look incredibly silly, no matter
how it was depicted.
Aside from these troubles, however, it was
also reported that Amazon's brass simply didn't
feel that the pilot was up to snuff, and that
it would have suffered by comparison with
other fantasy properties the streamer has
cooking, such as Lord of the Rings and The
Wheel of Time.
While that's certainly a bummer for fans,
there is a silver lining here.
As the 2017 film proved, The Dark Tower is
an extremely easy property to botch, and we
submit that it's totally possible the powers
that be at Amazon have actually saved us from
another half-baked adaptation.
Who knows?
As to whether any other brave souls will pick
up the Dark Tower torch, it's tough to say.
It's always possible that Mazzara's series
will be rescued by Netflix or HBO, but it
seems more likely that whatever problems Amazon
had with the pilot won't be overlooked by
other potentially interested parties.
If indeed some intrepid creator decides to
start from scratch on a fresh adaptation,
they would do well to heed the advice of Ron
Howard, who produced the feature film and
also oversaw a planned tie-in TV series, which
never materialized.
Speaking with Collider last year, Howard indicated
that if he had it to do over again, he would
have leaned into the weirdness of the source
material rather than trying to shoehorn it
into a mainstream-friendly package.
He told the outlet,
"We always felt like we were kind of holding
back something.
Sometimes this happens on these projects where
everybody's best intentions, you're all pulling
in a direction, and then you sort of say,
'Was that the right direction?'
And I wouldn't say [the movie] was all compromise.
I do think it was just a sense of maybe too
much listening to what you think that the
marketplace is calling for instead of the
essence of what Stephen King was giving us."
Hopefully, one day, we'll get the mind-blowing
serial adaptation that The Dark Tower deserves,
but it likely won't come from Amazon.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
movies and TV shows are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.